Speaker 1: A follow up to a story from last
week.
This is pretty interesting.
Jesse Lee Peterson caused a car accident across
the street from his Christian Young Men's
Counseling center when being asked questions
by someone on the street.
And Dr. Richard Richey covered it.
He also covered my coverage of Jesse Lee Peterson.
I'll give you the back story.
Jesse Lee Peterson is this very outspoken
pro-Trump, black conservative pastor, and
he's very homophobic.
He has spent his career talking about sin
and being gay is bad and all these different
things.
And now numerous individuals have come forward
saying they were in gay relationships with
Jesse Lee Peterson, that they were accosted,
for lack of a better term, by Jesse Lee Peterson.
And I told my story last week of how when
I was in his studio, Jesse Lee Peterson was
very handsy with me.
I didn't make much of it, and it wasn't sexual
harassment or whatever.
Well, a Dr. Richard Richey covered this.
He mentions my coverage of Jesse Lee Peterson
and he has the video of this car accident
that was caused by Jesse Lee looking like
he's going to step out in front of fast moving
traffic to try to get away from these questions.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: Follow up not only is and tie LGBTQ
pastor Jason Lee Peterson gay, he's a predator.
He may have been hit on David Pakman and he
ran away and caused an accident when someone
confronted him.
There's a video.
Hey, Jesse Peterson.
Martin Francis here.
How are you?
Speaker 1: So this is the post office right
across the street from his studio, which I
visited.
Speaker 2: So I'm the first man in your whole
career.
Speaker 3: I am the first man in your whole
career that you have run from, like the chicken
song that you play.
You are running from me.
Speaker 1: So now Jesse Lee is approaching
a crosswalk.
Sometimes traffic gets going pretty fast here
and he looks like he's just going to step
right into it.
Car slams on its brakes, car behind it slams
into that car.
Speaker 3: You're running from your car.
From your car.
What you've been doing for 31 years.
Speaker 2: I always build here.
But Jesse Lee.
Speaker 1: Doesn't even react to the car wreck.
Speaker 3: He causes Jesse so upset that he
tried to cross the street before he should
have and cause these cars to stop in March.
Speaker 1: And that's pretty serious damage
to each other.
So what's.
Speaker 3: Because.
Speaker 1: What is this?
Speaker 3: I now have video proof, more so
than before.
Tell me about your wife.
Speaker 1: Tell me about you sleeping with
your brother's wife.
So quite a scene there, folks.
Jesse Lee Peterson quite literally causing
an accident out on the road as he stepped
in.
Now, I want to mention a couple of different
things about this story.
Number one, after I said last week that Jesse
was just very touchy with me, I'm so just
that was my personal experience.
I got a bunch of emails from people saying,
David, don't you think he realized that you're
that you're gay and that you're open to a
relationship with him or whatever?
Okay.
I'm not gay.
And also he wasn't.
Publicly acknowledging that he was gay at
the time either.
So that's like a really strange thing to send
me.
Number two, some people wrote to me saying,
David, why are you outing Jesse Lee Peterson?
Jesse Lee Peterson has not acknowledged that
he is gay.
So you're doing something wrong?
No, I have not outed Jesse Peterson.
I'm reporting on stories written about him.
That's what I'm doing.
So the people writing to me and saying even
talking about it is wrong, as if I'm the one
asserting that he's gay.
I have no personal knowledge of that.
We're talking about widely reported claims.
And number three, would I go back on his show?
Sure.
Yeah, absolutely.
I would love to go on his show and talk about
this.
Why did it why did he feel as though he couldn't
just be who he was?
That's terribly sad.
And I would want to revisit my conversation
with him where he said he was celibate.
There's a lot I would want to talk to him
about, so absolutely I would appear on his
show again